welcome back to fox and france we're
going to go straight to a fox news alert
the senate
will now take up the bill to boost
stimulus checks to two thousand dollars
the president showing his support
overnight tweeting quote give the people
two thousand dollars not six hundred
they have suffered enough the measure
passing the house 275
to 134 only 44 republicans support the
president's plan
as many are worried about the price tag
bernie sanders is threatening to
filibuster the vote to override
president trump's veto to get the senate
to vote
on the bigger stimulus checks someone i
think very capable of addressing this
divide within the republican party quite
frankly
this divide over populism and perhaps
new concern
or recent concern about deficits is fox
news contributor
and former speaker of the house it's
newt gingrich who's also the author of
trump and the american future
newt we're so glad to have you um i'm
very interested in your perspective when
it comes to this
i think growing fight among republicans
on whether or not to continue
president trump's populist push on the
party which these two thousand dollar
covenant stimulus checks
i think represent versus concern over
deficits which are real
but we have republicans some of whom are
going to support president trump on
these checks and others
think now is the time to refocus on
deficits
what do you think republicans should be
doing with president trump's call to
increase these checks
okay i'm the only speaker of the house
in your lifetime who's balanced the
federal budget for four straight years
so i believe in balanced budgets but
this is like being in world war ii
uh we have a disaster in this country
made dramatically worse
by democratic governors in places like
california illinois new york
who have been crushing small business
killing the restaurant industry
leaving the average person you know the
big losers have been middle class
americans
the big winners have been the very rich
and
government employees who got paid for
not doing any work including
millions of members of the teachers
union who didn't do any work but got
literally collectively billions of
dollars for sitting around
so i think if you're an average everyday
person you're looking at all this mess
and you think the government has clearly
not done its job
particularly the state government's led
by democrats and
two thousand dollars will help me uh i
think that's what's going
on i think when you're in the middle of
a crisis like this or like world war ii
phase one is to get out of the crisis uh
frankly the tragedy of biden
potentially becoming president is if he
goes back to obama's police failed
policies
we'll get no economic growth we'll have
high unemployment
the only answer to the balanced budget
is to have very dramatic levels of
growth and
underlying structural reforms you're not
going to get either of those
in a democratic presidency
speaker welcome to the show we're you
know as you know only one week out from
the georgia runoffs
no one knows the state better than you
tell us you know what
what you're seeing on the ground what
you're hearing from your friends in
georgia
and also let's talk a little bit about
the democrats who are sounding an alarm
saying that they need more money what
does that tell you about
the the state of the race well look if
you've got if you've got terrible
candidates
more money just increases the size of
the bankruptcy
uh the big thing to me in the last two
weeks
we've suddenly realized not only how
radical
raphael warnock is and a lot of his
views
and his endorsement for example of
reverend wright's
sermon that talked about gd america
and that the chickens would come home to
roost at 9 11
but also warnock's personal problems
with his ex-wife
and warnock's apparent failure to run a
children's camp
several years back where they now have
you know an eyewitness uh
now in his early 30s talking about how
terrible the camp was how abused
children were
and that warnock was responsible so
warnick i think is in deep
free fall now on ossif's case we've now
discovered that he lied about
how much money he was getting out of
china he's been paid by the chinese
apparently for several companies
does not release the amount of money and
coming on top of what we've seen
with swalwell the the democratic
congressman
who had a relationship with the chinese
communist spy
and with what we've seen with hunter
biden i think gossip now has a big
problem
i mean do you really want a a chinese
communist-sponsored
u.s senator from georgia i think most
georgians are going to say no
but you know nude ossoff may actually
you know he almost won a house seat that
you know well
that's very conservative traditional
seat so things are clearly changing
there
i want to ask you because we have
senator lefler coming up in just less
than a half an hour and we're going to
ask her about her potential votes
do you think the president put lefleur
and purdue in a difficult spot
now with this push for the two thousand
dollar
checks as the senate may have to vote on
it
look the last the only survey i've seen
actually
says about eighty percent of the
american people favor
the president's proposal and i think
it's because as i said a minute ago the
average american knows instinctively
that the really rich have done well the
government employees getting paid full
time for doing nothing have done well
and that if you're an average american
you you've been battered
including in democratic states by
terrible terrible policies
so there's a huge underlying groundswell
for what trump wants to do
obviously senator lefler has to make her
own mind up but my advice would be
to vote for it because we we are in a
situation
where the present united states has
appealed to his own base he's coming to
georgia
on monday night to campaign for both
senator leflar and senator perdue and
his turning out his base is central
to their winning uh i think they will
win and i think in the long run
uh that this is just one more piece of
data it's not
not going to define things by itself but
on the other hand i would say
you're not this is not about deficit
spending uh that
that train has gone long gone we're in
the middle of a disaster
i think the average american deserves
some help the very rich have done
obscenely well
out of rising price stock values etc
the public employee unions have done
absurdly well
not going to work while collecting full
paychecks
which is why you don't get pressure on
the left to do anything except
crush small businesses and crush
restaurants
and people's ability to go to
church i mean it's it's really been a
weird couple months
yeah and i think the president who's
pretty good intuitively at this stuff
has figured out a winning formula and i
i would just say the average republican
when a big enough train comes through uh
it's just as
well for you not to throw yourself on
the tracks and get run over
yes a disaster created by china when it
comes to the virus in government when it
comes to shutting down
our economy a disaster we need to come
out of as you say newt
you brought up my lifetime a little bit
earlier you being the only speaker to
balance a budget in my lifetime let's do
this
let's look back in history if we can
last night i said this newt
i said the democratic party has veered
further left and at any point in
american history since the 1930s
now nikki haley said something similar
she tweeted that 2020
was the year that socialism went
mainstream the dangerous ideology which
has failed everywhere it has been
tried and ruined countless lives and
it's on its way to become the default
economic policy of the democratic party
this terrifying trend threatens the
future of every american
the left believes that government knows
best if the past years taught us
anything
it's that when government dictates how
the economy is run americans suffer and
with the abide administration set to
take power
now is the time to renew the fight for
capitalism those are the words of nikki
haley
do you agree that socialism seems to be
going mainstream
well absolutely and that's because the
universities
have been abandoned to marxist and
socialists and for two generations
uh they've been teaching young people
things that are just not true
uh and so uh you know you're graduating
a lot of people think venezuela is a
success story or
cuba's a success story uh which is a
total denial of reality
but i would the only thing i would
change about what you just said is the
the current democratic party is way to
the left
of franklin delano roosevelt in the
1930s
he would have opposed virtually
everything he was against welfare
he was for work requirements uh he would
have thought much of what they advocate
is crazy
uh so i i think this is the most radical
party which is why in georgia
it makes perfect sense that they
nominated radicals
uh warnock is the most radical candidate
i think ever nominated in american
history
by any major party uh and ossif is very
radical basically
a san francisco nancy pelosi kamala
harris liberal
who gets twice as much money from
california as he does from georgia
and it was no accident that when they
got to the runoff both warnock
and assaf did a fundraiser at a san
francisco restaurant
as their first fundraising event uh in
the runoff so
uh i think they just typify the modern
democratic party
which is proving at the state level that
it loves dictatorship
that hates church and hates synagogue uh
it is it is uh
it hates small business it hates
restaurants but it loves big government
uh and it loves dictating the people how
they can live their lives